often people think that Switzerland
wealth comes only because of their
status as a fiscal Haven so think about
it there are other countries like Panama
Cyprus the Republic of Liberia
these are fiscal Athens - don't forget
Africa not only offers low taxes to
international companies but it's also
offers them capacity refills these
countries remain low income countries
while Switzerland remains one of the
wealthiest countries in the world and
all this comes with them having no
natural resources not compromising on
democracy or stupid right if I
Switzerland have one of the most
egalitarian political systems in the
world and its welfare system is as good
as that of Norway Denmark additionally
their citizen is nothing we have the
right to vote every four years but every
four months
the Swiss don't just choose their
leaders that they choose their policies
with referendums happening several times
a year Switzerland has one of the
world's best political systems and we
believe that this is the reason that
they are successful in fact we think
that the Swift system should be a model
for other countries and in this video
we're going to tell you why
with some number1 decentralization from
a practical point of view
Switzerland is what is known as a
confederation in fact it's the only
Confederation that exists on the planet
it is made up of 26 states which are
called Canton the only thing that these
Kansans have in common are a
constitution foreign policy and the
currency aside from that they are
totally different from one another let's
look at an example let's say you make a
salary of six thousand Swiss francs and
you live in the region of Jura in that
case you're going to pay income tax of
14% but if you made the same amount of
money and you live in the region of the
zhuge your income tax is only going to
be 4%
[Music]
let's look at a different example if you
have a shop in Geneva then you're going
to have to close your shop at 6 p.m. but
if you own a shop in Zurich you're free
to keep your shop open for as many hours
and you want because of the system
candles can adjust their laws Sakuni era
teas of each individual territory and
what is even more important than this is
that they can compete with each other
this explains why in general the
councils have such low taxation but our
story doesn't end here
Switzerland is so decentralized that
they have four official languages German
French Italian and Romansh this means
that if you have to go to Geneva which
is a french-speaking part you're not
going to hear anyone speaking German the
billboards the road signs the local
newspapers everything is in French the
same goes for Zurich with German or
Lugano with Italian
number two Switzerland has no president
every country has a head of government
who is responsible for certain things
right well no not Whitmer but don't get
me wrong they're not division Anarchy or
anything this is what they do they vote
for a Federal Parliament which is
similar to Congress in the United States
of America this Parliament then chooses
seven people who are going to become
something like ministers or secretaries
all of these people have the same amount
of power
each year one of them takes a turn
becoming Switzerland international
representative technically this person
uses the president of Switzerland but
they have no specific powers over the
other six people and as I said they
rotate this person every year this is an
important difference in the twist
mentality because in other countries the
president is mean really powerful
fascist but in Switzerland it's just a
symbolic thing because all of the
decision-making is done by a team number
three they erect democracy this is the
most important part of Swiss politics
and back of vengeance in fact most of
their laws are chosen by a popular vote
some at the federal level some of the
cantonal level the proposal for a
referendum only requires 50,000
signatures while one that's it's going
to amend the Constitution requires
100,000 now don't get me wrong other
countries do allow their populations to
have referendums for example in Spain
this is totally possible but a
referendum proposal requires 500,000
signatures and they can't do any
referendums that will change the
constitution
because of this system Switzerland holds
several referendums every single year
every four months this way go to the
polling station and they will vote on
any proposals that have been put forward
in the previous four months now let's
look at an example of one of these
referendums from the Year 2015 they had
to choose whether they wanted to create
a basic income for every Swiss citizens
they said no by the way they also had to
decide on some amendments to the
assisted reproduction Act and the also
at devotions and laws related to public
transport interestingly these poles
often have a really big turnout 60% of
Swiss people for this 2015 referendum
went to the polls number for free-market
some of you might think that it's very
easy for a populist anti-capitalist
leader to emerge in a system like this
but make no mistake
Switzerland is to the free market like
France is to its wine
don't forget this country is isolated in
the mountains and has practically no
farming map this means that it has to
find free trade agreements with pretty
much every country on Earth but hold on
my dear libertarian friends who are
watching this video hold on for just one
second yes it is true that Switzerland
is a commerce loving nation but no more
so than the European Union
this is a twist actually subsidized
their agriculture as much as the
European or the Americans do and they
also participate in the same trade
embargoes that exists with Iran and
Russia the only differences that
Switzerland has embraced free trade
since 1874 while the rest of the world
has only been doing it for the last few
decades and now there is another very
important difference about Switzerland
that we must get into and it's probably
one that you've heard recent number five
recent neutrality Switzerland is one of
these few neutral countries in the world
this means that they won't participate
in any armed conflict they even stayed
out of world war two despite the fact
that most of the population was against
Hitler thanks to this Switzerland has
never been reconstructed while the rest
of Europe ripped itself apart killing
millions and then spending billions in
reconstruction Switzerland dinners and
they used all of those savings to
improve their system as we all know the
number one enemy of economic program is
war or that Switzerland does have a
military the thing is this army is
entirely defensive and they will only
use it to propel external attacks they
will never use it to fight in anything
outside of self-defense and this is
where we see one of the few drawbacks of
the Swiss system then military or should
we say their militia every Swiss citizen
must view military service from the age
of eighteen to the age of thirty
spending one month every single year
serving in the military and even after
that service period they must still keep
a Janus home of course Switzerland isn't
the only country that does this with
Norway and Israel also having mandatory
military service
[Music]
plenty of people argue that this system
is good with pundits saying that it
creates more entrepreneurs and creates
less income despairity don't forget that
during their time in the military is a
rich and the poor are mixing together
several startups and companies have been
created from relationships that were
formed while people were serving in the
military but the big question is what
about Liberty what about the freedom to
choose what gives the government the
right to force you to work in a place
that you might not want to work of
course we don't have the answers to
these questions that they are just
something for you to ponder twisting
number six ease of doing business
finally there is perhaps the most
well-known thing about Switzerland and
that is they're active it's true despite
the differences from one candle to
another Switzerland though typically has
very low taxation further the laws first
off company are fairly simple and anyone
can see those laws by just going online
Switzerland is one of the most
transparent countries in the world
this has encouraged a lot of
international companies to establish
their fiscal residence in Switzerland
but it also makes it very easy for
people in Switzerland to set up their
own company and yes ok-okay banks do
make up a large part of the Swiss
economy but it's probably not as big as
you
there are many many other industries in
Switzerland does the name logitech mean
anything to you well and look at your
mouth look at your webcam you'll
probably see it printed on one of those
things and this is a company that was
formed in Switzerland and then there's a
pharmaceutical so the names Novartis or
hoffman-laroche ring any bells not to
mention of course tourism precision
machinery and their famous watches I'm
pretty sure you could mean five
companies that are from Switzerland of
simplifying meanings and expensive watch
brands and all of this is being done in
a country with a population that is
smaller than New York City as we always
their visual politic it is not the
country's natural resources and it is
not luck but determine whether they are
successful it's their system of
government and their institutions
Vasudha and we believe that the Swiss
have a lot to teach the rest of the
world in this regard so that is just our
opinion do you agree with us do you
disagree with us do you things that your
country could benefit from a system more
like the Swiss let me know what you
think in the comments below and don't
forget that we upload brand new videos
every Monday every Thursday so you click
that subscribe button and if you would
like to dig deeper on this topic and
find out more about the Twitter system I
will put some links in the description
below and if you like this video don't
forget to give it a thumbs up below and
[Music]